[Music]
how do you like that it's pretty good
can you just up real quick yeah give him
a critique hey did you take thai ball
dude that's sick don't die mo billy
blanks me dude
damn
pretty good dude not that the chair was
just glowing yo can you teach me how to
like shadow box where i look sick as
[ __ ] but i never want to fight nobody
that's my specialty all right that's
what i train people to do that's tight
if you want to learn how to fight that's
not me do you really train me i do train
people in boxing yeah yeah but like you
know soccer moms stuff like that like
this look ready my best student wait you
train you train boxers
uh mma guys yeah yeah but not like
boxing
the more you ask him the different
answers
this is firefighters
mostly grocery store owners that's it
that's all i really train just his mom
he fought himself
this guy doesn't know what to take
seriously
tastes like i don't know this guy i'm so
sorry man that's all i want to say
that's training people yeah all right so
uh a couple weeks ago we actually did a
little episode on hugh hefner and [ __ ]
that happens in the playboy mansion but
wait didn't he pass away yeah okay cool
but they're talking about in the past
got it okay okay but according to a new
documentary
hugh hefner demanded orgies five nights
a week and drugged women you demand how
do you demand the orgy i demand a
[ __ ] orgy hugh hefner he walks around
in a [ __ ] robe 24 7. i want to know
how he demanded it though like how did
he ask i just want to it's just it's
just mind-blowing probably on the
intercom okay everybody go on the living
room
oh no
gross that's pretty good my [ __ ] would
go
speakers everywhere so this new uh money
is round up or some [ __ ] you know
bunnies round up
bunnies hop on over yeah something like
that it's bunny time look at this
oh man that's the five times a week five
times a week yeah that's way too much it
is the playboy match you still got two
days off what do you expect though only
changes five days a week right no way
that guy could be same thing bro no way
that hugh hefner could be a boxer he had
no legs about time you do this thank you
you get knocked out every fight dude got
it
do you think he slowed down his orginess
well you keep on talking about this like
as he got older because i'm thinking was
that during the 70s or like when he was
younger because then like by the time
you know
i remember like he had a tv show all
that stuff this will look like [ __ ]
he was ancient already that was a
nymphomaniac then well yeah he started
playboy so i would assume that
why would you assume that he's the king
of perverts what if he's just an
entrepreneur and he saw a [ __ ]
there's a need in the market he's in the
market specifically for a naked nudey
magazine actually in the 50s
i would expect some more money
entrepreneur i would expect someone to
not get high off their own supply and i
thought hugh hef was actually asexual
and then he saw uh uh uh he saw a dream
and then he says i'm gonna provide this
thank you joseph you're welcome but i
found out he's a pervert
[Laughter]
i literally try to [ __ ] give the
information like six times
it's not the first time he hears you're
killing the dream nothing has changed
not a goddamn thing has changed i'm not
even going to share anything in the
article let me just start making up [ __ ]
that's what everyone says
bunny hops
anthony can you please tell me can you
please tell me look i have eye contact
i'm done all right i'm done go continue
i'm done i just have to put it out there
god
an upcoming documentary series named
secrets of playboy is set to lift off
the lid on the dark side of notorious
brand and its founder hugh hefner
including accusations of him demanding
orgies and drugging women
so in this freaking documentary right
they've got uh his two main past
girlfriends which were heidi something
heidi something what holly madison
sanja theodore yeah
yeah so it contains exclusive interviews
from them and uh pretty much theodore
who's now 65 recalled orgies at the
mansion five nights a week which became
protocol and she was also uh witnessed
firsthand how his sexual demands would
start turning nasty and admitting that
he's kind of nasty like good nasty i
think it was like more bad nasty like on
my chest
she said she said uh he would scare
and uh
she was afraid that you couldn't satisfy
him he wanted more and more and more oh
he's a sexual demon
damn she said the group's sex was at
least five nights a week they had a
protocol he liked to direct and you
didn't segway from it because you could
tell it irritated him
so imagine being like very very powerful
as well and wanting things to go a
certain way and you would just have to
play along so he's like you didn't
[ __ ] eat her ass the way i wanted you
to [ __ ] i can't work with these dumbass
actors you know oh yeah that's joe's i
mean by far the most okay now now
[ __ ] you
you lick her toe and then when she's
feeling like this you put a finger in
her [ __ ] right now and then it's right
fingers it says i'm white it's not
[ __ ] right
don't put two fingers in there like i
can't work under these [ __ ]
conditions you know those are literal
[ __ ] conditions there's some there's
something weird about this because uh
you know how they're like when you hear
this news now it sounds like it's
supposed to be problematic like people
are supposed to be like oh my god like
you're waiting for outrage to happen but
if this [ __ ] was happening from the 70s
when people openly could talk about it
and it was cool why is that like
why is it coming out now you know what i
mean like because he's dead and he can't
back himself up yeah but it's like it's
like this could be the exact same story
word for word but when it happened in
the 70s and all of it would be cool like
none of it would be like and also it's
his house too so i'd be like every time
i go to anthony's house he makes me do
this and this
then don't go to his house
you know i don't know is that a is that
a weird argument with my name in it it
gets weird bro
well every time i go to nick's house
every time i go to anthony's house you
always make it underneath orange juice
i just gotta go with this dude and it's
like well isn't it my choice to go to
nick's house yeah every time i sleep
over there and i use a shower use his
kitchen he makes me do this and this you
should have seen what bart made me and
ryan do when we stayed over yeah you put
us in the sex room and you said we had
to [ __ ] you're like you had us you had
three beds and you made us use one yeah
dude what kind of [ __ ] is that wait we
told you to go upstairs yeah i know we
those aren't trolls yeah it was it was
our uh we're trying to have orgies five
times a week i'm just curious what
attracts women
to wanna go to hugh's house in the first
place because like fame power money so
okay they go there for that reason no
one is so strong he's basically a pimp
and there's probably going to be
sex orgies
and like nudity because he basically
built a career off of nudity and sex
right so like
i don't really understand why yeah yeah
like so it's like this because gossip
goes out right and you hear
oh so that's the two fingers in the
[ __ ] house
sure i want to go next time i don't want
to walk into the lion's den
and then do all this [ __ ] not not saying
that this is okay or anything like that
maybe maybe like light at the end of the
tunnel maybe not just going in the
tunnel there's like there's a concept of
like oh i want to be on a magazine no no
yeah well but but then that's the thing
right it's like light at the end urethra
not not you know
we got to trade carefully here but it's
like
now we do here's the thing so okay
here's the thing right it's like
you know
this is there's a house full of
gangsters
but you know you think they're kind of
cool and then you're like let me go play
with fire a little bit and hang out with
these guys because they're fun to party
with right
but then a shooting happens or like
something happens you don't want you
don't like that but you played with fire
so
it's kind of like this like if you know
that weird things happen in this house
why do you want to go there like you
know what i mean i'd argue that maybe
there's a certain population of people
that don't know that this is what's
happening and then on the pretense and
they get tricked and then it becomes
this whole like systematic thing where
they're like oh you know i thought i was
going here for magazines
i don't know i'm sure i'm sure there's a
combination of both i'm sure there's
people that go there knowing what
they're going to get into there's
another population of women that have no
idea there's probably all these people
that are like i'm down to like live rent
free and get fed and service yeah you
know what i mean all i gotta do is put
out and then maybe i can be on a
magazine get famous get paid you know
what i mean i think there's some glory
into it more than just like going into
like a gangster's house i bet it wasn't
clear up front
maybe i think that's the thing because i
would be like all right i just gotta
show my titties cool right and i walk in
and i'm like i didn't know how to eat
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah was that an applause like what
is this because that's what it sounds
like
it's like
i mean i'm i'm a nude model but i don't
[ __ ] do drugs and they're like well
to stay here you got to smoke crack and
you're like hold the [ __ ] phone man
or like you're just [ __ ]
doing some sex and then afterwards you
know like
what the [ __ ] is that that's the
international sign of sex yeah you're
doing some sex and then hugh head starts
peeing on you and you're like what the
[ __ ] bro yeah i just wanna [ __ ]
i was here just to [ __ ] and now you're
peeing on me yeah exactly like dangling
their careers or the possibility of it
like that's some weinstein [ __ ] right
that it's a combination you know i
wouldn't be surprised if that was the
case theodores uh also said that hefner
was a prolific drug user who would send
her out to buy cocaine numerous times
and the sex broke me like you'd break a
horse
holly madison who dated hefner for eight
years detailed how hefner didn't want to
use protection and that the playboy
bunny lifestyle led her to even
contemplate suicide at one point damn
definitely get somewhere i don't i don't
know if it's eating kaka or anything and
we have to remember two um uh at least a
lot of us in this room we don't have any
issue bringing [ __ ] up or just walking
out of [ __ ] right like we're not like
push up not pushovers that's the wrong
word but we're not people that um
if we don't like something we're not
gonna stay around and they're not me and
brandon don't [ __ ] take [ __ ] oh yeah
dude
and some people
come on
i take [ __ ] all the time that's [ __ ]
dude and there's some people there are
some people that
you eat [ __ ] no uh that don't feel
comfortable in in like confrontation so
maybe for them they feel like they're
trapped and they don't have other
choices and [ __ ] but also though too
it's like sometimes they don't even
realize what's happening when they're
it's way harder to look at your
situation when you're in it versus
five years removed when you'd be like yo
that was kind of [ __ ] up that's when
playboy was like a bigger game in town
like now like what we're talking about
only fans like you guys that's true but
back then like when playboy was like the
top are they blockbuster now
are they the blockbuster of like i think
so
of yeah they're like a minute ago bro
catch up
yeah
well cause they went digital like what
eight years ago or something like that
they didn't even have paper no more
that's stupid
so they also mentioned that hefner
really did believe he owned these women
uh we had playmates that overdosed that
committed suicide wow hefner's executive
assistant during the 70s and 80s
shares her side of the series in the
series as well she spoke of hefner's
stockpile of quaaludes a powerful
sedative which he called the leg
spreaders oh no you got a name and you
have a stockpile and that's ghb but
that's the rape drug
that is the rape drug that's [ __ ]
nuts man but then uh like during that
well not during that time but like if
you think about what happened with
[ __ ] uh weinstein right and like it's
like when um
media had was centralized to one place
like if you were like a nude model and
you wanted to make it there was only
playboy back in the day so it's like you
either do this or you don't have a
career yeah and then but hustler was
like the dirt
more hardcore playboy was like the
gentleman style like
yeah and then penthouse hustler all that
was like porn even though playboy is
kind of borderline but it was the more
like it can get you somewhere more like
a square-ish yeah because now the women
are more like i got only fans i could be
my own boss yeah there's it's different
but back then they had to work around
this like pimp situation and that's the
same thing with a lot of actresses in
hollywood and actors who had to put out
to producers
if they wanted to get to a certain place
and it's like that's kind of cool now
that now people can they don't have to
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] and then people are
getting called out yeah yeah
damn that's shady as [ __ ] but back then
that's what they had to do to [ __ ]
make it that's crazy yeah because back
then it's like the exploitation was a
one-way road now it's like you can
re-exploit someone after they get you
it's like like what they're doing right
now yeah like they went through the
years of all that [ __ ] now it's like
times have changed and now they have
like a platform to be like i should do
this [ __ ] i'd eat cocka yeah i don't
know if that was an article i just now i
feel like yeah
they said it got nastier and nastier i'm
just assuming where else could you go
besides poop yeah where else is there to
go yes the final level of dante's
inferno eating [ __ ] after [ __ ] is
straight to poop
i guarantee you he got bored of [ __ ]
getting his dick sucked
[Music]
you